so at the end of the dark world
Loki is on the throne the beginning of
Ragnarok Thor has a few questions and
Loki is endearingly enigmatic about
providing answers Tiaka Waititi is such a
spirited hilarious individual and he and
chris became very fast friends and I was
a great for me to do is to see that
friendship kind of blossom and they
brought out the best in each other and
started making stuff up and i can
confidently say right now this will be
the funniest detection of the character
of sore that either the scene i
personally have known for almost 10
years that chris hemsworth is hilarious, I
think this go-around will be his chance
hey everybody is Charlie! So Tom Hiddleston
dropped a whole bunch of extra information
about Ragnarok in addition to the steps
in this clip something to a breakdown
the tagline is that he basically crapped
his pants at the site of hela so he
runs to the door and that's sort of
where he picks up in this teaser here
Thor has a lot of questions Loki isn't
very forthcoming about answers so if
you're brand new to the channel i do
Marvel videos every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything I'm even
doing a doctor strange DVD giveaway and
speaking of which I'm gonna have to
reference them stuff from the end of
that movie so just be careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen doctor strange
yet a lot of this is all taken from
interviews that he's been doing for his
kong school island movie so he goes on
to say this is stuff that wasn't in that
clip but hammers are involved and stakes
are raised on paraphrasing him Cate
blanchette it's no secret is playing the
goddess of death who brings destruction
in her wake
and it's the kind of destruction that
both Thor and Loki have never seen on a
scale of terror that they've never seen
before so they fall back on their
Brotherhood so that's actually a really
big thing fractured though it is to see
what they can do to stop her
that's the loki thor through line so you
have to imagine that they both like each
other remember that funny captain
america scene where loki put on the
costume like he makes himself look like
Captain America maybe you'd rather have
one of your adventures friends with you
on this journey so you really like that
and he likes to torment Thor the way
that brothers torment each other so even
though he has all these feelings of
being an outsider being an outcast
because he is part frost giant he still
feels this very brotherly bond with or
it'll come through in the movie in a way
that I don't think that it came through
during dark world you felt a little bit
of their camaraderie but a lot of the
characters got lost in that movie and I
think that's why thor ragnarok like one
of the big reasons why it's going to be
a lot better because they're focusing
more on the characters but they've also
got all that crazy spectacle to get the
planet hold stuff they have hela they
have ragnarok itself but racing the
through line from what Tom Hiddleston
set to the official synopsis of the
movie Thor imprisoned on the other side
of the universe without his mighty
hammer in finds himself in a race
against time to get back to ask card to
stop ragnarök the destruction of the
film world in the end of
Guardian civilization at the hands of an
all-powerful new threat the ruthless
ella but first he must survive a deadly
gladiatorial contests that pits them
against his former ally and fellow
adventurer the incredible hulk so
between all the teasers they've been
dropping recently between the concept
footage the infinity war stuff we've
actually seen a bunch of thor ragnarok
so far and even if you have like a broad
idea of jack kirby storyline you know
that it's the destruction of Asgard
where some of the gods live some of them
die and are reborn as new versions of
themselves so there's this endless cycle
of death and rebirth in the universe i
don't know how they're going to explain
that in the movies they might make her
more of an Angela character because
that's kind of the vibe that she's
giving up but she herself is part frost
giant just like low-key in her power is
so great that they might even tune it
down just a little bit in the movies
she has the ability to call the actual
souls of a certain percentage of debt as
guardian
so if you don't know angela is she's
actually a pretty cool character that
neil gaiman created that belong to dark
horse for a while Todd McFarlane there
was this big legal battle but he got her
back so Marvel started using her and
made her the daughter of Odin the lost
daughter of Odin so she's basically just
a super badass character imagine her
being like a much crazier version of
tomorrow like you thinking more in the
Guardians trailer holding this giant
weapon
just imagine Angela holding two of those
at the same time but he mostly uses
sword in the context of the comics
there's this other realm called heaven
which is the tenth realm that Odin field
off and erased all records of what they
were able to steal one of his children
when they escaped
so Angela comes back later seeking her
revenge against Odin and the forces of
Asgard having her mind be a little bit
twisted hela story in the comics is
kind of like that too except it's more
of a Lucifer type story like imagine
Lucifer getting banished to hel and
forced to preside over all those sold so
hela is really pissed but she gains all
these extra powers so the way they
explain her in the movie so far the
synopsis that we've gotten is that she's
seeking ragnarok the destruction of all
of the nine realms not just as guardian
society
but the way they've been teasing it so
far they're just talking about the
destruction of Asgardian society but
really it's much bigger than that
because if Loki didn't crap his pants
when the Dark Elves started to destroy
Asgard you have to imagine that
something that would make him crap his
pants is way worse so that is where we
get to ragnarok which is sort of the pre
lewd for infinity war because pianos is
trying to do the same thing on a
universal scale you have to imagine like
Doctor Strange hops between different
dimensions
there's a difference identity got--let
between different realities so
multiverse many Infinity Gauntlet many
versions of a nose trying to erase all
life so we're not quite there yet we're
sort of localized to the ncu 616 or
whatever you want to call it like the
single universe
Dormammu was sort of waiting in the
wings for phase for stuff that's going
to be happening later on
speaking of dr. strange stuff so the
funny thing that Tom Hiddleston said is
that Loki is completely unimpressed with
dr. Strange's sorcery
he's like oh that's cool but I've been
doing that for centuries
so what's the big deal so even though he
doesn't appear in that Doctor Strange post credit
scene he will probably appear with doctor
strange on-screen in the Ragnarok
because they want to hold something back
for the actual movie in the whole point
of that post credit scene was just show
you what the dynamics is going to be
like with Doctor strange interacting with
the regular adventures because this is
the first time we've seen the character
you have no idea what its gonna feel
like when he's with all those other
characters but if you didn't already
think the Chris Hemsworth in benedict
cumberbatch were supercool they actually
improv that whole scene so when Tom
Hiddleston says that chris hemsworth is
one of the funniest actors that he's
ever worked with and he'll finally get a
chance to show it indoor ragnarok that
just means that you'll see a little bit
of that Dubrow humor Thor has so let me
know in the comments what do you guys
think about all this craziness is going
to be so awesome and a lot of you been
requesting bonus videos about sores
weapons so there will be a day or two
during the week that I dedicate to NC
you video stuff for the Marvel movies
like Avengers videos stuff four-door
spider-man movies haven't quite figured
out which days
it's going to be but i'll try to post an
update on the schedule in the next
couple of days
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts that you don't miss anything
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Anthony banfield please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so i can get your contact details
it was a new round that started in this
video i will be posting some more
Avengers infinity war stuff later this
week so i'll announce the winner
whenever I post that but I've got some
more Deadpool that's coming there's a new
injustice 2 evil Superman trailer that
is crazy that i will post later tonight
so it's going to be awesome
while i'm working on that get on some of
this Thor behind the scenes it's
actually pretty cool and you can click
here to rewatch that infinity war teaser
thank you so much for watching let's
high five, i'll see you guys in the next video!